hey man it's me Kevin Smith urging you  to subscribe to the Kevin Smith channel  this is the channel on YouTube all about  what my mom wants to see 24/7 Kevin  Smith I told my mom I'd create my own  network just first as you could watch me  she's like tiger I'm so proud you're my  favorite thing on that channel the only  thing on the channel what's coming  though Batman on Batman that's gonna be  our flagship show me and mark barnard  sitting there talking about all the big  news then we're gonna throw up all sorts  of fun geeky stuff including watch me  weep watching the flash like this not  embarrassing oh yeah man I'm gonna do  stuff like that probably video myself  taking a crap put that up see if that  gets any hits man anything for relevancy  so stick around tell your friends  subscribe to the Kevin Smith challenge  youtube.com slash Kevin Smith we're  gonna have fun and no silence Bob  you